we all know that in our on demand lives
one of the things that's most On Demand
is
ourselves many of us have the Sensation
that we're standing about 2 in away from
a huge screen and it's noisy and it's
it's crowded and it's changing with
every second and that screen is our
lives and it's only by stepping back and
holding still that we can begin to see
what the canvas
[Music]
means one of the first things you learn
when you travel is that nowhere is
magical unless you can bring the right
eyes to it I found that the best way
that I could develop more attentive and
more more appreciative eyes was oddly by
going nowhere just by sitting
still in an age of constant movement
nothing is so urgent as sitting
[Music]
[Applause]
still
[Music]